this is the last week before the
inauguration of president elect Donald
Trump as president of the United States
it's also the last week for our
crowdfunding campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate we have tons of
perks we have all sorts of great stuff
available to you and I'm glad that
people are taking advantage of the perks
but really the most important thing here
is the goal of this campaign we've got
to support independent media during this
upcoming Trump administration I if
you've been paying any attention to the
way Donald Trump has been relating to
media if you say something he likes
you're great you're his best friend if
you say something he doesn't like you're
a liar and by the way he wants to change
the laws to making lawsuits against
media easier to bring forward so we need
coordinated independent progressive
media under Donald Trump and that's
exactly what we're trying to do we have
built the david pakman show to the point
where we where we currently are 200 plus
radio and TV stations the nightly eleven
o'clock show on free speech TV on
directv and dish network over two
hundred and eighty-five thousand
subscribers on youtube a very popular
podcast we've done it all because of the
support of our audience and we are going
to you if you want us to do these new
things which i will tell you about then
please do donate it david pakman.com
slash donate the big thing is we are
going to create a progressive engagement
coordinator that is going to work not
just on reporting stuff the way we do
but on coalescing and catalyzing
progressive activism what campaigns
should all progressives we will be
working on who should we be calling
about particular issues or problems or
news stories that require engagement
from the people and the progressive
engagement coordinator will be working
not only with us but with a number of
independent progressive media shows to
really exponentially grow our impact we
also are going to grow the distribution
of the david pakman show to include
amazon prime video this is just huge
amazon prime video whatever you think
about amazon amazon prime video is
undeniably like youtube has become
becoming a bigger and bigger
distribution platform for video and the
opportunity we have if we have
right manpower to do it to get on Amazon
Prime video is absolutely huge and we
plan to put that in place as well with
the fundraising from this campaign and
the studio that is behind me this kind
of a couple of screens and and otherwise
a black background we are going to tweak
it in a way that will really add to the
professionalism and the look of the show
that I think you're really going to like
I've been checking out the drafts of the
proposals from our set designer as to
what this will look like and we're going
back and forth and I think it's going to
be extraordinary that is also something
we're looking to fund with this campaign
so please whether you can donate a
dollar or 501 dollars or a thousand
dollars or ten thousand dollars whatever
you can contribute please do because
every donation gets us a little bit
closer to our goal go to david
pakman.com slash donate this is it
midnight on Donald Trump's inauguration
day the campaign ends